[Music]
betsy starts off this hour in baltimore
maryland hi betsy how are you
hi dave i'm fine thank you for taking my
call my pleasure how can we help
a few years ago i got divorced after 21
years
and three years ago i
bought a house and
i'll just say that i really didn't have
all my wits about me
and i bought a house from a flipper and
i
didn't have i thought i had a realtor
that i could trust
and it turned out that i didn't so i had
this
92 year old house that needs
a fair amount of work um i was also
talked into um getting
a seven year arm mortgage
and i'm in the third year
what do you owe on the house i owe
100 i guess i owe about 180.
okay i think that's about where it is
now if you were to put it on the market
without doing any work to it like it
sits
today what could you get for it
well i paid 275.
if you were to put it on the market
today like it sits
with the work that it needs on it what
could you get for it
well that's my issue because my
conscience says that what is the house
worth
i i would say it would probably go on
the market for 275 i just don't know if
i
mean you think it'll bring that
i think it could good yes good get
within a real estate elp at
ramseysolutions.com get it on the market
and sell it
that was my question i didn't know
whether i should
get out of this yes and get out of it
yes okay everything you described in
this entire
conversation was the opposite of fun
right well yeah it did the house became
more than i
thought the deal was bad going in and
the deal has been bad since you sat
there and you've got a bad mortgage
right there's nothing here that is
happiness
no on top of that it is a reminder of
the mindset you were in
of a poor state you were in when your
life fell apart
it's just a reminder every day it is it
is
get out of it yeah the broken house kind
of feels like the broken you that
went in and bought the broken house
every time you drive up in front of it
do i do i sell it as is yes ma'am yes
ma'am you're not in the business of
rehabbing
there's somebody that would have already
seen so much hgtv that's going to run
right into this thing
yeah there's a chip and joanna out there
somewhere but they're smiling big
and hey will you do me a huge favor yes
the next time you buy a house the next
time you rent a house
i want you to change your language and
this is important because it's going to
make you walk a little bit taller
i want you to change your language from
i got talked into
and to i did it it was dumb
i did it i went in a good state i did
this and now i'm gonna make it right
i'm gonna sell it i'm gonna sell it as
is i'm gonna make a hundred thousand
dollars so i'm gonna put down another
property
that i've got my wits about me i'm gonna
make good decisions get good counsel
and i'm gonna stand six inches taller
starting today so you're going to
understand
the deal you're going to understand what
the property is worth you're going to
understand what you're getting into
so that no matter how competent or
incompetent who you're dealing with is
that you're not going to be taken they
got to go through betsy from maryland
right right
i just was concerned about if i move out
of here
and the houses are so expensive
listen even if you go rent for a while
and you you know you it takes you a
while to find a reasonable deal
the market has to calm down before you
find a reasonable deal
nothing about the deal that you're in is
fun
and so this is a really good time to get
out of an unfun
deal okay okay
and is summertime okay or should i have
better betty betty
salad betsy how long have you been
divorced
uh four years four and a half years was
that a surprise did it shock you
it wasn't a shock but was it devastating
the whole thing was a lie
the whole thing was alive so it was
devastating okay here's what has not
happened in four years
you've not learned to trust betsy again
that's true and the marriage fell apart
but at the end of the day you blame
betsy betsy should have known
and at this point you've got to stand
back up and say betsy is worth
being trusted is worth good counsels
worth good friends
is worth not having to ask 17 different
questions
when one of the smartest guys in america
is telling you what to do
john i was talking about myself not you
clearly
clearly clearly clearly me not you yeah
the trick is trust me betsy there's
gonna be a lot of peace that comes if
you just go keep your life real simple
and rent a nice place for a little while
and you got a little pile of money in
the bank and you don't have any issues
anymore
and all of the emotions and the problems
that this house represents and the
regrets that this house represents are
in the rear view mirror
and the windshield is bigger than the
rear view mirror we call that grace
look forward look forward and give betsy
grace
yeah yeah you're okay you're you're
smarter than you're giving yourself
credit for you're stronger than you're
giving yourself credit for
good stuff open phones at triple eight
eight two five
five two two five you know we always say
personal finance is eighty percent
behavior
it's twenty percent head knowledge um
and i i have always anecdotally seen the
correlation between
bad decisions
being paralyzed on making a decision uh
to the things that have happened in
somebody's life i mean um
we had a caller in another hour that had
gone through chemo
followed by pandemic the these are not
financial things
but they always affect financial things
right
and financial things always affect them
that's exactly right and so this idea
that somehow money is its own little
category
siloed over here to the side from your
emotions your relationships your
betrayals your hurts
your physical well-being um
your the time you were molested when you
were 7
49 years ago uh all of these things play
into your money that's right
and they play into like you said your
marriages and your work relationships it
plays into all that stuff
and we dave we have a um we've got a
society a culture that says
you are the worst thing you've ever done
you
are the worst thing that's ever happened
to you and we do not have a collective
sense either individually or
as a culture of what redemption looks
like
what's saying i made a stupid decision
and i'm better than that i'm not going
to do it again and what going forward
looks like
and we see folks like betsy who are good
people who are trapped in that
that cyclone of doubt and shame from the
past from the past
and the the hardest person to get over
doubting is yourself yeah
good stuff this is the ramsey show